Today's feature presenter is Bill Burnett.
Bill is an Adjunct Professor
of Mechanical Engineering and
the Executive Director of
the Design Program at Stanford.
He directs the undergraduate and
graduate programs and designs and
teaches at the D School.
He received his Bachelors of Science and
Masters of Science in product design
at Stanford University, and has worked
in start-ups and Fortune 100 companies
including seven years at Apple
designing award winning laptops and
a number of years in the toy industry
designing Star Wars action figures.
He holds a number of mechanical and
design patents and design awards, and
in addition to his duties at Stanford,
he is on the board of Voz, a socially
responsible fashion startup, and
advises several other startup companies.
And now,
I'd like to turn the floor over to Bill.
>> Hello everybody.
Today's webinar we're calling Cultivate
Your Creativity and it's really about how
you can make yourself and probably
the teams you work with more creative, and
therefore, bring innovation either to your
life or to the work that you're doing.
And we've got a lot to talk about today so
let's jump right into it.
This is a quote, you can't dig a new
hole by digging the old one deeper.
It's from a guy named Edward De Bono.
We should have a little note on that.
Aside from that, but
Edward De Bono's probably,
you know the grand master of creativity,
literature.
He's written over 57 books.
On the subject of brainstorming and
what he called lateral thinking.
And so it's a good way to
start is to think about.
So how many times are we
stuck in a problem and
we just keep coming up with the same
old solutions over and over again?
Just keep digging that same hole deeper.
And you're really not
going to get to new and
creative ideas until we change
our frame of reference.
And so, the way we do that here at
the disco it's all based on this idea
called design thinking.
A lot of people,
when they hear the word design,
they think of design as sort of a craft,
where you’re sculpting products,
you’re sculpting graphics or
something like that.
At Stanford we’ve generalized the idea of
design to a methodology of innovation,
that David Kelley Renamed design
thinking because methodology of
information is hard to say.
See, I just had a hard time saying it.
And design thinking is this process where
we say you don't start with the problem,
you start with people,
you start with empathy.
Then typically redefine
the problem you're working on.
because a lot of times we find
folks are working really hard and
pretty creatively on problems, but
they're working on the wrong problem.
There's a famous quote from
The guy who was big shot,
the dean of business in the business
school world, Peter Drucker.
And he used to say, there's nothing so
useless as doing something very well that
should never have been
done in the first place.
So a lot of the time, it's really
about redefining the problem and
then building your way forward with
this prototype and test cycle.
What I'm going to talk about more
today is what we call the mind sets or
the point of view of the designer.
How design thinkers, approach problems.
We like to approach
problems with curiosity.
Most of us are taught in business and
in life to be kind of skeptical realists,
and that's great.
But when you're trying to do
something creative you really want to
lean into your curiosity.
And then you want to re-frame the problem,
because typically people
are working on the wrong thing.
Radical collaboration just
means that the interesting
information about this new idea you're
going to have is out in the world and
you need to collaborate
with others to find it.
My input process in this case were mostly
going to talk about the divergent process
of creativity.
Having more and better ideas.
But there's also the converging
process of deciding what you want to
build in prototype.
So you want to be aware of are you
diverging or converging in the process.
And then when you're
talking about creativity,
we think of bias to action
is the most important thing.
Just start trying things.
And one of the things you try
is techniques to make yourself
more creative and to have better ideas.
Design thinking, therefore is this sort of
new approach to problem solving because,
and it works well in this kind
of human creative problems and
is a new approach, really, to problem
finding by reframing problems in
figuring out what you want to work
on that's more interesting than
the thing that was probably presented
to you as the original question.
And then it's a new
perspective on value creation.
And certainly when we're talking
about design thinking in terms of
innovation strategy for a company,
here I'm talking about creating value,
creating more profits.
Today we're just going to talk mostly
about how you create new opportunities and
exciting ideas in your own life.
So we're going to focus mostly on,
in the design thinking framework,
on this ideation bubble.
And I want to talk to you first
about this idea of creativity.
So what is creativity in the first place?
The definition from the dictionary,
it's a state or quality of being creative,
that's not very helpful have the ability
to transcend traditional ideas and
create meaningful new ideas.
And so a lot of times I think people
think that creativity has some kind of in
breed talent and moreover we think of it
here just the ability to have new and
different ideas whenever you want to.
Whenever you're in a situation
where new ideas would be useful,
you want to invoke your creativity.
So we have a quick poll for
you, and here's that question.
Were you more creative as a child?
I want you to think back to when you
were only five, six, seven years old.
Just as you were starting,
we'll say before you started first grade
because I think school has a big impact on
creativity and
when you think back to that little kid.
Was that little kid more creative
in some ways than you are today?
Was that little kid the person who could
kind of come up with wild ideas and
crazy ideas?
They're turning a stick into a toy,
can turn a rock into a spaceship,
that kind of thing.
So quick poll, yes or no,
were you more creative as a child?
Maybe about 20 seconds to hit the button.
Okay, do we have- Any results yet?
All right, so about 42% of you thought
you were more creative as a child,
and 14% said you weren't, and
then I guess the 44% is I'm not sure.
That pretty much parallels the polling
results we've got in the past.
And I do this in a live class.
People have a conversation about this,
and sometimes people who say, no,
I think I'm more creative now are really
saying, I'm more intelligent now.
I have more facts to work with.
And therefore, I think I'm more creative.
But I think creativity isn't so
much about intelligence or facts or
knowledge about a certain stance,
it's about the ability to think very,
very widely and laterally about any
problems you are presented with.
I'm going to get into a couple ideas
about how you can be more creative
than you are today.
So just dive a little deeper into
this notion, what is creativity?
Well, there's a new frame
of reference around
how things in the body evolved and
it's called neural Darwinism.
It's basically saying that the brain
evolved like all the other
organs in your body, in competition
with all the other things in your
body that needed energy to run.
You eat about 2000 calories a day
that's what you run your body on.
And the brain is for you a processor,
it takes 500 calories,
almost 25% of the energy that you consume
every day just to run your brain.
And our theory is that what's happened is
the brain evolved, as big as it is, but
it's limited.
It can't get any bigger because if it
If it took any more energy to run it,
the body simply wouldn't function.
Well when you think about it,
40 watts is not very much, all right?
So the brain has evolved to
adapt to process information
at the lowest possible energy state.
The fewest possible neurons to fire for
any problem that it encounters.
Now the brain is an amazingly
complex organism, but
nevertheless it has to make really
quick decisions really fast and
with very little energy in
order to process the billions
of bits of information that flow
into your body every second.
So if you look at some work from Dan
Goldman who was the guy who wrote the book
on emotional intelligence and Don Norman,
who are both cognitive psychologists.
They have this model of
how the brain works, and
it's quite different than
the way we sort of think.
Most people, when I ask them,
well, how does your brain work?
They say well my eyes,
and my ears, and my body.
Absorbs all this information and
then I process it and I make the response.
It's actually more complex than that.
The stimulus comes in to what's
part of the brain's each
of the sensory systems that sort of
censor and filter that information.
Many of your sensory systems are analog.
It turns into sort of digital information.
And then it's thrown up into
the memory systems in your brain and
it's schematized into simple,
chunk-able facts.
We have a schema for table, a schema for
chairs, a schema for computer.
So when you look at these things, you can
process the individual information very,
very rapidly with very
few bits of information.
And we encode things visually, verbally,
kinesthetically, through motion,
through patterns,
through musical representation.
And then what actually happens
is that part of your brain
makes two things happen.
One, unconscious responses,
when you drove to work today and
you remember how you did it and
consciously responding to the environment.
It also has this little thing
called pre-consciousness which
decides what you are going
to become aware of.
And that becomes the thing you
have a conscious response to.
The pre-consciousness system is actually
trying to figure out what's
going to happen next?
And it's knitting together all this
information in a complete narrative.
The problem is, of course,
those schemas limit what you're
capable of even imagining.
Let me give you an example of a schema.
This is a picture of Roger Bannister, who
was a medical student at the time, only
trained like three days a week because
he had to go to med school in London.
And in 1954, he was the first
person to run a 4-minute mile.
And prior to that,
people had said it was impossible for
a human to run a 4-minute mile.
The body couldn't go that fast.
The kinesthesiology and
the muscles wouldn't work.
Well, Roger was a natural
creative in many ways.
And he just didn't accept
that as the truth and
then he broke the 4-minute mile barrier.
And of course,
then what happened is right after that,
16 runners had broken that same
barrier in less than three years.
And now it is over 1,000 runners who
have achieved more than a 4-minute mile.
So it wasn't so much that the human
body changed or nutrition or
anything got better.
It was the fact that prior to
Roger running the 4-minute mile,
everybody assumed the schema,
it's impossible.
And therefore, they were limited in
their ability to make an attempt.
Once the schema had been broken or once
a new schema had been established, many,
many people had access to it.
So what's my point?
My point is to two things,
you're bringing chunks of information into
really tiny bits of data and
it processes efficiently as it can.
And then it tells you what to look for.
There's a number of experiments where
people are asked to look for something and
then something else happens and
they don't see it.
And this is because our brains are
actually putting together the narrative of
our experience, our conscious experience
by processing all this information and
making only a little bit
of it available to us.
So psychologists say we don't really
see what you're looking at directly.
You only see what you're looking for.
And that's compounded by
the fact that our consciousness,
this grasping of reality actually
lasts less than a half a second.
Now we have a memory system that's
writing the short and long term memory.
And then we have this sort of
consciousness, this sort of, well,
the shutter clicks, we get a frame, and
that clicks about every 300 milliseconds.
Our short term memory builds that into
a continuous perception of the world, and
our long term memory draws on all these
other schemas that sort of sort the world
out and tell us what's going on.
Now, you might ask, how do we know this?
Well, there was unfortunately a patient
that had had a pretty severe brain tumor.
And when it was operated on successfully,
unfortunately, lost
the ability the connect his short-term and
his long-term memory to his consciousness.
And he lived in essentially a 300
millisecond, a less than half a second
world, where every half a second
the world reappeared to him.
And he had no way to connect the dots,
a very scary kind of way to live.
Although, a very bright person, high IQ.
Had all the other attributes
of a normal human being.
He just could not form
a consistent view of reality.
For those of you who remember the movie
Memento, it was the same thing.
That person had only short term memory.
So every seven or eight minutes, he forgot
everything that had happened to him and
the world reappeared, and
new conversations happened with people
that he'd known for years and years.
So here's the trick,
your brain is collecting these 300
millisecond flashes of information.
It's sorting them down to a very small
amount that you're actually aware of, and
knitting them together in
a comprehensive narrative.
So you feel like you
understand the world and
everything that you see is
everything that there is.
But in fact,
it's just creating kind of this movie or
this video game of the world.
So if that's way perception actually
works, we have the opportunity
to use what we know about that to
increase our ability to have new ideas.
And recent findings on creativity,
again from brain research, and all of
this stuff will probably change as we get
more and more information about the brain.
Nowadays, with FMRI scans and
PET scans and
other things, we can watch the brain
working on certain problems, and
we can deduct from those as observations
how creativity is happening.
So there are tests for
high creative people.
And we measure the high
creative people versus normals.
And we notice three things about them.
One, they have more visual and
more tactile awareness of the world,
more parts of their brain light up
when they see and touch things.
They have a high social awareness
response, which is the empathy response.
Many times, high creatives are introverts.
So it's not that they're social people,
it's just that they notice
social interactions.
They're highly empathetic
to other people's feelings.
But the one that's interesting,
they have what psychologists call
a low fear response to novelty.
Low fear response to novelty
means they basically,
when shown something they've
never seen before in a scanner,
the part of their brain that should light
up and go I haven't seen this before.
And the flight, fight or freeze response
should trigger, the amygdala and
other parts of the brain.
That just doesn't happen to them.
They see something that they've never
seen before and they don't frighten.
So the thing that's interesting about that
is that's a totally trainable function.
You could learn low fear
response to novelty.
The other word for that, by the way,
commonly held in the culture is curiosity.
So instead of going what's that?
They go!
What's that?
And then they move towards
things that are unusual.
The work of Albert Bandura,
this famous psychologist who teaches here
at Stanford on ridding people of phobias.
This idea of a guided mastery,
take very small steps and
eventually learn to overcome your phobia.
Is the basis of what we teach in
brainstorming, what we teach for
mind mapping, what we teach for
other creativity techniques where we
train people to lower their fear of
doing something unusual or novel.
Which is just baked into us,
it's an evolutionary thing that you would
want to be fearful of something
that's unknown, right?
You're walking through the jungle and
something jumps out at you and
you can't identify it, it might eat you,
you would want to have that fear response.
But we have creatives, creatives
are left in the gene pool we think,
because when situations change,
you need people who naturally come up with
ideas that no one else would have had.
They were probably the people who
in caveman days, cave dweller days,
or when everyone else was out hunting they
were painting pictures on the side of
the cave and no one could quite
figure out what to do with them.
You know these people.
They're your friends who are artists or
poets or designers or
writers or something.
They often are socially awkward because
they don't pick up on the clues of society
that tend to narrow our
perception of what is possible.
And they retain a sort of childlike but
sometimes clumsy sort of creativity
as they move through the world.
So this is totally learnable.
We can teach people to
lower their fear response.
And to generate ideas without censoring.
But my point about all this
sort of neuroscience here, and
I don't want to get lost in it too much,
is that we are, in fact, in a box.
This out of the box thinking
is not really possible.
What is possible it to
understand a few things.
The box is real.
So that's just the way our brains evolved,
and there's nothing wrong with you if you
feel like, hey,
I'm not as creative as the next person.
That's not the issue.
The creativity is
probably a brain deficit.
So this thing where we scan people
who don't have fear response,
that's actually a part of a circuit in
their brain that's supposed to be working.
But it's broken.
So that's okay, because that's actually
good news, because that means we can train
that part of your brain to turn off when
you want to have access to creativity.
You're actually in a better state
than a high creative person,
because they don't have any
access to fear response, so
they constantly bumping into things in
culture where they say the wrong thing or
do the wrong thing, and
they don't understand why.
You understand culture and the culture of
your community, your personal culture,
the people around you, and
the culture of your company.
So you can turn on and
off your creativity whenever you want to,
once you're trained to do it.
Creativity is a high-energy
brain behavior.
Brains don't like to operate at
40 Watts and full circuits on.
But you can train yourself to do that.
It's just like aerobic training.
And creativity therefore can be learned,
which is really important is
that's what we do here at Stanford and at
the D school and in the design programs.
We teach people to be more creative.
So we're teaching them to
lower their fear of failure.
We're teach them that the brain
organizes things by schema.
So just change the schema and
your brain will automatically
change the kinds of idea it has.
When we're brainstorming and people get
stuck, I say, okay, now let's imagine
we're on Mars, and gravity was
one-fifth the gravity of the Earth.
What would we do?
And
then they have a whole bunch of new ideas,
and they change the schema again,
and so
now imagine that we're all elephants.
We have to make this interaction
happen with our trunks.
Now what will you do?
And it's just a game to get people to
break out of the set they were in and
try a new set.
And then, all of those ideas
becomes possible in the brainstorm.
And then we down select for
the ones we can turn into something
that's actually actionable.
And so you can access this
improvisational intelligence,
this kinesthetic intelligence, and
all these other things once you
understand how the box is organized.
So in the, I'm going to give you three
ideas and a couple of techniques for
doing this.
One, the first one seems to like,
it's a little bit counterintuitive.
I want you to train yourself to get stuck.
I want you to put yourself in
circumstances where you get stuck
over and over again.
Literally, your brain freezes and
you just don't have any ideas.
The one I do a lot with executives and
folks who come into
the master class that we'll talk about
later is the 30 circles exercise.
It's a very simple exercise.
You just take a piece of paper
that's got 30 circles on it,
six rows of five circles.
And I say turn the circles into something.
And I give him a couple of prompts
like you could make a smiley face,
you could make a flower.
And there's a number of
variations on this exercise.
1,000 uses for a paperclip.
Or pick any common object that people
have labelled as either boring or
dull or not good,
like a good fodder for creativity.
Take anything and say now change
this into a million other things, or
a hundred other things.
And people get stuck because
they drop into schemas.
Well, a circle can only be face or
a circle can only be a flower, and
I'm not going to talk about the ways
you soft quote solve this problem.
But what happens in this exercise is they
have an experience of getting stuck and
I ask them to examine what
that experience is like.
Most people do have an idea.
They have a what we call a a-ha moment,
when they realize, I could, I don't have
to make just make flowers, I could
make baseballs and soccer balls, and.
And that's a moment where their
creativity kind of bursts forward.
And once you understand
the sort of the cycle of that,
this mindful of process,
the getting stuck, the a-ha moment that
follows right after that, then the getting
stuck again and the a-ha moment.
When I scan your brain during
this exercise, when you're stuck,
your flight or flight or freeze response
is triggered, your fear response.
Get away, this is a dangerous problem.
You're failing in front of the professor.
Stop, stop, run.
But when you have the ah-ha moment
your brain is generating endorphins
both the left and right hemispheres
are firing in synchrony, and
you're really going into
the problem in a new way.
So I want you to train yourself to be
stuck and then have find the ah-ha moment,
be stuck and find the ah-ha moment.
The misunderstanding about designers and
this design thinking thing is that somehow
we're very facile and we never get
stuck and we solve all the problems.
No, in fact,
since we've decided to sign up for
a career where we get a new problem
every day that we've never seen before,
we almost always start stuck,
and then discover a way forward.
So this learning to not be
afraid of being stuck, and
learning how to find the a-ha moment,
is the first trick.
Second trick, people do brainstorming.
I just came back from a workshop where
I was teaching some brainstorming, and
it was probably the worst brainstorming
I've ever seen people do.
But we got somewhere, and we did it two or
three rounds and we got better and better.
So everybody can get better.
But here's the deal.
Most people think about
brainstorming get in a room,
somebody says let's come up with bunch
of ideas that improve something.
And we make,
we all talk at once and we put some things
on the board and then we think it's done.
I want you to create a new metaphor in
your mind for a brainstorming group.
I want you to think about music.
I want you to think about jazz.
Jazz is the one form of music where
musicians agree to get together and
play a song we've all played before.
But while we play that song, to make
music none of us have ever heard before.
We're going to improvise on that game.
But when it really works,
take that to some place completely new.
So this ability to
improvise in the moment,
that's what brainstorming is really about.
Now, you wouldn't expect to be able
to sit in with a great jazz ensemble.
Miles Davis and the Kind of Blue is
the best-selling jazz album of all time.
You wouldn't expect to sit in
if you were a beginner, right?
If I said, here, here's your saxophone,
go play with these guys over here
who have been playing for 30 years.
You would know you were out of place.
You would know that it's not,
that's not appropriate.
I didn't understand why people,
when they get together and
they have much practice with brainstorming
think, we're going to do this really well.
You have to practice.
And at first the mechanics,
just the simple mechanics of everyone
having an idea,
listening to each to each other.
When you, the solo in the brainstorm
is when you present an idea and
everybody else is supporting you.
But passing the lead back and forth is
letting someone else present an idea.
So the mechanics of just getting
that done are quite difficult.
But I notice when I'm working with people,
let's say I have a team of five and
I say hey, Ronny.
Do you think you could have
just one idea every minute?
Like every 60 seconds,
let's say we're trying to come
up with new ways to do webinars.
Could you have one idea,
one idea a minute, that's easy.
But then I go, well, there's five people
on the team, so that's one idea a minute
times five times five, we should have had
25 ideas, and this team only had seven.
So clearly, the mechanics of
learning to listen to each other and
passing the lead back and
forth are a bit tricky.
But the mechanics alone do not get
you to that place where you've
practiced on your instrument.
You're bringing long enough and
hard enough so that you can actually
then let go in the moment and create.
It's this 10,000-hour problem from
Malcolm Gladwell's stuff on creativity and
on high-performance people.
Now, there's some controversy
about whether 10,000
hours is actually a real metric or not.
But let's just take that as a metaphor,
that it's
going to take you 100 hours to move from
just, I don't know what I'm doing to okay,
I understand the rules and I understand
how this piece of music plays.
It's going to take maybe another
1,000 hours to get to the sort
of expert on this thing,
some competency, the expert.
And I do think it takes many, many, many
years of practice to learn to put your
brain in this frictionless state where all
the ideas that available are possible.
And that where you can move from schema
to schema to schema almost without
knowing it, and
constantly generate new ideas.
So this inventing in the moment
is really a master skill,
and it comes only after a lot of practice.
So if you're having brainstorming
sessions that are less
Productive than you think they should be.
And I've used that metric
of one idea a minute
times another minute times
the number of people.
That's a novice brainstorm,
a pretty good brainstorm
of people have done this before except
we will easily be able to double that.
An idea every 30 seconds is not fast,
and that would generate
50 ideas from a team of 5 and if you
tripled that, it would generate 75 ideas.
And I have student teams
who practiced on this and
I have expert teams with senior designs
who practiced on this who can easily
with a team of five have a 100 to 150
ideas in five minutes, that's mastery.
If your teams are nowhere
near that number yet.
Just practice, it's just practice.
It takes a long time to learn play
that saxophone that is your brain and
you know, you're going to have to
put in the hours because I don't
know any other way to do it.
And you know,
get in the 10,000 hours to mastery.
Okay, it's also true that
it's a mind body problem.
Is getting into this state of
relaxed tension and flow so
that you just have ideas over and
over again.
You gotta go from the analytic side of
your brain to you synthesis side of your
brain and you don't have to necessarily
sit in a full lotus position but you have
to be relaxed and here's the other thing,
when people do these brainstorming stuff
in companies and teams,
they just come from a budget meeting.
They just come from a negotiation or
something.
They're totally in their left brain,
and so
they need some opportunity
to sort of warm up.
Quiet down the prefrontal cortex,
excite the right brain and
the cognitive processes that are there,
and context and meaning and emotion.
because all of those things
are going to result in better ideas.
So in order to do that,
you have to warm up.
What we use at the D School
is a lot of improv games.
A fantastic book by Patricia Ryan Madson,
who was the professor of improv here
in the drama department here for
30 years and was considered one of
the most extraordinary teachers
on campus she wrote a book called “Improv
Wisdom: Don't Prepare Just Show Up”.
And we have tones of her improv
stuff from improv theater,
tradition games called Sound Ball where
you're throwing around imaginary balls
Proverbs, you're making imaginary poems,
and
then this notion that they have in improv
of no matter what just happened on stage,
the only thing you're
allowed to say is yes.
And build on that to be the next thing.
If you're looking for
a bunch of improv games we put up a bunch.
We've got a whole appendix
from Designing Your Life book.
It's up on our site,
www.designingyour.life is the URL,
and you can go download a copy of
all improvs we use at the D School,
about 20 different games that are there.
And they're broken into
sort of low impact,
high impact Improv to stoke up
the team and get them excited.
Improv to get the team
communicating better.
But we highly suggest
improvisation as a way of building
that sort of improv muscle,
that will then lead to higher creativity.
The other thing about brain
storms is people tend to
stop after they've looked over the ideas,
and that's not when you end.
You end with the idea of selection,
sort of framing and naming the ideas and
bringing them back to reality
in a way that's actionable.
If you choose around the usual criteria,
can we do this?
Is it feasible?
You'll get pretty incremental results.
We suggest you choose around potential and
pick words that excite
emotional connections.
Like what's the most delightful idea,
what's the most abstract idea?
What's the idea?
If we could avoid one law of physics,
gravity, or
one law of economics, like profit
What would be the most exciting idea?
And that way you'll not limit your
access to being able to frame
stuff that turns out to
be really actionable.
So here's the deal, brainstorming will
absolutely transform you, as a person,
because it changes your behavior.
The data shows that novices brainstorm
poorly, and great brainstorming
is like great jazz you have to be
expert enough to create in the moment.
That comes from practice and then you need
to improve your output by warming up with
improve games and selecting better
when you get to the end for
the ideas that have the most potential.
Third idea is space, not this kind
of space but this kind of space.
When you walk into a room that looks like
this, and most of you have been students
probably at some point in your life
realize I know what I'm supposed to do.
I'm supposed to sit down, shut up and
be passive receiver of information, i.e.,
someone's going to lecture at me.
In a space like this,
you cannot be creative.
My friends over at IDEO
have a great saying,
also when you think about
most corporate spaces.
Little cubicles that people sit in and
they're all divided from each other and
they can't see each other.
They say if you live in a cubicle world,
you will think cubicle thoughts, little,
tiny square thoughts.
You gotta get out of
those kinds of spaces.
This is the kind of space we work in.
This is one of the studios at
the D School, everything's on wheels,
it's a very collaborative space.
It's quite colorful, we have tools around
for instantaneous brainstorming sessions,
and also for
instantaneous prototyping sessions.
Raw, there's been a bunch of studies.
There was a Harvard study of
36,000 scientific papers,
all ranked on innovation.
And the two significant things
that they noticed about
the most innovative papers is
that innovators were co-located.
In other words,
this idea of radical collaboration.
People from different parts of the
organization were all sitting together,
and the fact that they had really
different backgrounds, and really
different ways of framing the ideas,
tended to juice up the innovation content.
And that they mostly worked in raw or
easily modified environments.
There was a famous building,
Building 20 at MIT.
Which was constructed as a temporary
building just around World War II for
some advanced research that MIT
thanked us for doing for the military.
And it was just a space that nobody
paid any attention to or took care of.
And here you'll hear it was just this
crappy building that people who could not
get good space at MIT were assigned and it
turns out that that is where all the big
innovations came and
the patents came from the MIT environment.
So Raw space, this idea of space creating
behaviour, is such a powerful metaphor.
We suggest,
if you want to be more creative,
be in a more creative environment.
Create sort of like this war room, or
this project room place for yourself.
Even if you do it at home for
your own personal projects, make the
things that you're working on persistent.
Put up the pic.
It's like a physical Pinterest.
Pick pictures of everything
that you're thinking about.
Put the pictures all up all the time.
Make sure that when you walk back in
to that room the information is the and
is crewing your subconscious
to think again.
Remove all the status clues, status and
hierarchy defeats creativity and
the d.school rooms there is no visible
hierarchy either, there's no stage,
there's no front,
there's no back to the room,
your rooms are completely self-authoring.
Everything's on wheels.
Everything can be hacked,
and nothing is precious.
So people believe when they walk into
these spaces that we're demanding their
creativity because their creativity
has to frame what the room looks like.
It's such a powerful, and
such a simple thing to do.
Just change your space.
Couple of guys, Scott Doorley and Scott
Witthoft wrote a book from the D School
called “Make Space,” which is kind of
the go-to reference for people who want to
try to either create more creative space
at home or creative space where they work.
It's such an important thing.
All right, so here's the takeaways.
Changing, if you want to
become more creative.
Then something has to change, right.
Something is going to change.
Now some people think you just read a
bunch of books and you think about it and
then you'll be more creative.
There's no evidence that that's true.
What is true is that if you
change your behavior you
will be indistinguishable
from a creative person.
I.e., if you start brainstorming,
if you are able to change
your schemas quickly
If you start developing a visual language,
you sketch a lot and you doodle a lot.
If you are the kind of person
who's more likely to say 'yes and
-' when someone has an idea instead of
'well, wait a minute, but that won't work.
If you can just change the mode of
the way you interact to a 'yes and' mode
You will one, have better ideas, two,
they will be more creative ideas and
three, whether you feel creative or
not you will be indistinguishable
from a creative person.
Because in our model creativity
is a series of behaviors and
by the way the behaviors, of course,
change you neurologically.
We studied one class, the class they
teach called the Designing Your Life
where students from all
over the university,
that are not in a creative major, they can
be in econ or history or whatever major,
they come into class with
sheets from these principles.
And we have measured an increase
in their ability to ideate from
the beginning of the class to the end and
what we're going to start doing next is
trying to see if we've actually
built new brain circuits.
We're going to scan them before and
after class.
But my theory is that this
behaviours are certainly going to
create new circuits in the brain
which will allow people to be
experience their life
had been more creative.
So, three powerful things get stuck more
often, challenge yourself with problems
you don't know how to solve them, wait for
and then work hard to get the AHA moment.
Move to this jazz model
of brainstorming and
create a space that demands new behaviors.
And then if you want to be this person,
one you have to act differently,
you have to act this way.
And you want to probably
reward yourself for
taking these kinds of risks and
certainly if you're managing team that
you want more creative behaviors from You
have to change their rewards as well.
Because most of the ideas that you
have as a creative person never
get realized in the world.
They're just part of creating
an environment, a culture of ideas,
a culture of creativity.
And in So,
you have to be able to reward people for
something other than
their direct production.
And, by the way, be patient.
To change behavior, I'm told from
the psychologists over in our psych
department, people who work on behavior
change to establish a new pattern or
habit takes at least, eight weeks.
And, it takes eight weeks
of concentrated focus.
It can't just be sort of, a side game.
And most of us don't
have the time to do that.
So be patient with yourself.
It may take a while to have these
new mindsets of curiosity and
radical collaboration, and reframing.
And better brainstorming and new spaces.
It may take a while for
that to take effect.
But once it does, you'll start discovering
that the world is a much more.
Interesting place and that your
curiosity will pull into really new and
interesting problems in a way that you
probably could not have predicted.
I always end the works that we do here,
because it is about changing people's
behavior, with a Gandhi quote, be
the change you want to see in the world.
You model these behaviors for
yourself, for your family, for
your kids Particularly so
important to remodeling the attitudes and
the yes and optimism of a creative
person for children, because they get so
little creative stimulation
unfortunately in our education system.
And also at work people will
notice you have changed, and
by changing you will change the world and
with that I'd like to turn it back
to Bill to take a few questions
from you in the time that we have.
So, Bill one question that we received,
a person was asking.
Is it better to practice
brainstorming on kind of
real challenges that you have at work or
as part of your job or
whether it’s better to start
practicing on model fake?
Sample problems,
which one is more effective?
>> Well, I think if you're
going to follow your curiosity,
you want to be working on problems
that you are interested in.
And when we We do workshops and stuff,
we have a bunch of model problems
we designed that have all
sorts of little tricks and
traps in them in ways of getting people
stuck in their schematic thinking.
If you're just trying to practice and
build up your skill,
working on stuff that you have some
Stake in some emotional stake in
the outcome is probably a good idea.
So real problems at work.
Assuming that you care about work and
the things that you're working on
would be excellent ways to do that.
And also,
just think about when you come home and
you guys are just trying
to figure out like.
We can't ever seem to keep this awful
schedule straight and we keep missing,
we're always late for soccer games.
How could we brainstorm 100 different ways
to make sure that we always pick going
to soccer games or whatever other family
challenges you have
are solved in a creative way.
And that would also include
probably bring your kids or
other people into their
brainstorming methodology.
And you might learn something from their
ability to be really non-linear and
open in thinking.
So, I think, I guess make sure to answer
is pick something you actually care about.
And I'm assuming you care
about the problems at work,
those would be great to brainstorm.
But pick things that your
curiosity pulls you towards, and
you'll do a better job because
you'll have a stake in the outcome.
>> So a couple of questions came
up about the space question.
People were intrigued about using
space to further creativity.
One question had to do with, how do
you remove status symbols [INAUDIBLE]?
And if you can say more about that
As well as the question around this
idea of co-location, the importance of
having people close together physically,
does that in any way interfere
with the fence of boundaries or
safety that people need in
order to be creative and open.
>> Okay,
well I think that the first one first,
it's
>> The idea, I mean, if you think about,
artists always work in studios
typically surrounded by other artists.
Designers work in a studio mode.
Well, if you go over to the IDEO offices,
and I'll just use IDEO as an example
as one of the most creative, innovative
strategy and product organizations around.
Also founded by one of our professors,
David Kelly.
[LAUGH] But
David came out of this program.
He was a graduate student
when I was a senior.
And, it's basically IDEO as
an example of this kind of thinking.
They always formed project rooms,
where people have their own office, but
when they're working on the project,
they're in the project room together.
And that allows them to minimize when you
are on the project team you are just on
the project team.
There's a project coordinator or lead,
but they don't have managerial authority
over anything other than the project,
the schedule, and keeping things moving.
It's not unusual to find artists and
musicians and
people working together
collaborating in these groups.
Musicians get together for
jam sessions You know,
artists get together for critique.
So, this idea of forming a space
where that kind of behavior is really
demanded and
accepted is what the space piece is about.
The idea of co-adaptation and
safety- That's interesting,
I never thought of collaborating
with other people as being unsafe.
But I could imagine in some work
environments that's the way
things had been set up.
Because in fact the team has been
pulled together from different
organizations, different
parts of the organization.
Really all have to individually go back to
the other part of the organization they're
from to get permission to do
what the team has decided to do.
And so that's an inherently unsafe place
because the team that's going to come
up with a bunch of great ideas and
then everyone's going to have to go back
to their boss and find out if that's okay.
So you know, if you're in that
kind of an environment we need
to work probably more on how do
we structure these teams, and
how are the teams empowered
to take on these challenges.
In some companies,
there's sort of a false promise made,
like we're going to form a task force.
And people are going to get together,
and they're going to solve this problem.
But in fact, what's really going on
is that people were put on the task
force because they weren't
vital to other projects.
Or the task force has not been
empowered to make anything
other than recommendations, all of
which get sort of ignored at the end.
And so you do want to be careful
in terms of your own safety
in an organization to find out whether or
not the projects you've been
assigned to is essentially real.
I'll give you a very simple
way of measuring that.
And this comes actually not from our work,
but
from some other people
who studied this problem.
Bob Sutton is one the guys here at
Stanford who studies this stuff.
Here's a good way to find out if
the team you're on is actually
empowered to make some decisions and
solve the problem.
Got a team of people and
you want to go talk to some customers, or
talk to a user or you just want to
go do some research some place.
Are you allowed to travel without getting
permission from somebody somewhere else?
So I mean I'm not talking first class
travel to Europe or something but
can you fly down to LA and
meet with an expert and
fly back without having to go
through some vice president.
Approval, because if you can't
authorize a $500 ticket,
you're not an empowered team,
it's just that really easy measure.
And it's interesting because, a lot of
these organizations have all of these
rules about travel and who can do it and
who can't do it and that kind of stuff And
they're all designed around control and
authority.
And so a team that actually has
the authority to travel and investigate
a problem any way they think is important
is actually a very empowered team.
Great, so a question around how you
decide who to put together on a team for
a successful idealization or
brainstorming process.
What are some key things that one should
think about as we're putting together
such a team?
And what do you think about
clients getting involved
in the process when you're trying to
come up with a solution for that client?
Well the idea of Radical Collaboration
is sort of how we form teams.
And to think about,
go back to music analogy,
we don't want six saxophone players.
We need a saxophone player.
We need a trumpet player.
Maybe we need a drummer.
We need a bass.
So we need people from different
disciplines that have some bearing or
insight on the problem we're working.
And that's tricky, because everybody's
coming from a different point of view, and
not everybody knows how to play together.
And so you might need to do some warm ups,
and some structured exercises
around how we're going to play together,
and exchange information.
I do think it's often really insightful
to bring the customer's voice in, whoever
that customer is, if you're a consulting
person, you're working with a client.
The client's the customer, but
the client always has their problem they
want you to solve for their business.
So they have a customer too.
So it's not always not only
the client that we bring in,
because the client may actually
suppress the conversation in a way.
Because their concern is that they want to
get a project done efficiently and quickly
and stuff that a brainstorm can look
like an inefficient part of the process.
But going directly to the customer,
the user that you want to engage with,
that's often very powerful.
I was seven years at Apple working on
the new, the first generation of laptops,
and a bunch of really
innovative stuff there.
Apple's known for that innovation.
And people say Apple doesn't do market
research But that's not actually true.
Apple does more customer
research than anyone I know.
We used to, we used to.
Hundreds of hours of standing behind
a one-way mirror watching people try to,
you know, get a laptop to send an email.
And all the confusion about software and
what's the operating system.
And what's an application to try
to make computers super easy,
the computers for the rest of us.
That anyone can use, kids could use,
teachers could use, and
they could set up their own networks.
Was really hard,
because software is hard to make simple.
And we used to test, and
test, and test, and test.
So we were always bringing the customer
and the user into the experience.
And sometimes into brainstorms.
because customers don't really know
what they want or what's next for them.
There's a famous Henry Ford quote that
if I'd asked people what they wanted,
they would have said faster horses.
By the way, there's no evidence
that Henry ever said that but
it's such a snarky thing
that he probably could've.
So customers don't know what they want,
but you can watch their behavior.
And they can suggest ideas
if they're of customer.
And sometimes you have those right on
the leading edge customers that are always
thinking about the next thing.
And that's a really good
person to add to a brainstorm.
But just like with a musical group,
I mean if people can't get along.
If people can't listen to each other,
if they can't exchange ideas and
state Stay on the then it won't work, and
sometimes you mix a group and
it just falls flat.
>> Yeah, so one request that we had
is if you can cure, an example,
maybe that would be
the last custom public.
If you can share an example of either,
as an outcome of a workshop or
a class here at the D school.
Or of the work you've done with companies
outside of Stanford where this design
thinking process has created
significant business results or
some other outcomes that
can give us an example?
>> Yeah, I'll give you one,
I know it's not directly related
to this one in my class, but it was in
a class called Launch Pad in the d.
school, where people get together,
they form little entrepreneurial teams and
they try to start a company.
And the absurd thing is with our
quarters are ten weeks long, so
you have to have a company with revenue in
ten weeks, which is a crazy, crazy idea.
So there were two young programmers
from the CS department, who had an idea,
just a very early version of
a news aggregator, like how
could their generation, the millennials,
don't read the New York Times, and stuff.
They just want to see snippets of news.
And nobody had really
done that very well yet.
This was back, I think,
three years, four years ago.
And they came to Launch Pad and they
had no design thinking training at all.
And but this is had an idea of how can
we get millennials to read more news?
So we forced them to go out to
coffee shops all over Palo Alto,
because there's lots of people in coffee
shops writing stuff, and working.
And one of the programmers was painfully
shy and wouldn't get out of the car,
and for the first sort of set
of ethnographic interviews.
because he just didn't like,
just uncomfortable and talk to people.
But they eventually broke
through that barrier and
they started prototyping things.
And they had some ideas about how maybe
to visually present little new snippets.
And then maybe to visually
organize those new snippets.
They built probably five or
six prototypes in the first three or
four weeks of the visual design
of this piece of software.
And then they would go over to the Coupa
Cafe in Palo Alto and just sit there.
And eventually someone will walk over and
say, what are you guys doing?
And they'd say,
we're working on this news thing.
You want to try it?
And they would get people to try it.
Week six of the quarter,
they launched their company.
Week eight of the quarter,
they already had first 10,000
users paying money to use this.
By week ten,
they were featured in a key note speech.
This was back when Steve Jobs
was still alive, so
must have been longer than four years.
And Steve talked about
this new news aggregator.
It was called Pace.
It was eventually launched
as a full company.
They were the number one news
aggregator software on the web.
This was before Flipbook and
some other things came along.
And they were purchased
a couple of years ago for
$90 million there's about $2 million
invested in the company, by LinkedIn.
So the LinkedIn news feed that you see
is in fact the software that these guys
wrote.
They've never designed a product before,
they've never done
ethnographic research or empathy before,
they were terrible at brain storming.
Two CS kids,
they were very linear in their thinking.
They're terrible at
brainstorming when they started.
But by learning to kind of use this
process to unleash their own creativity,
they're very creative,
very hard working, super sharp guys.
They created a product that
kind of set the pace for
our news aggregation and
really understood how millennials
adopt to small clips of news that
you can go deeper on and deeper on.
Came up with a really
lovely user interface.
It was easy to use.
And eventually it became
the basis of LinkedIn's news feed.
I've got half a dozen
other examples of things.
>> One's fine.
>> That's one of many, but what I like
about it is it started with people
who had no design experience at all.
And then ended up,
just through the process of iteration and
paying attention to customers and
brainstorming a lot, they came up
with something that turned out be one of
the leading products in their domain.
>> Well, thank you so much Bill.
We have many, many more questions but
of course we won't have
time to answer all of them.
Hopefully some of you will be able to
meet us here on campus in June and
address these questions and many others
over the course of these three days.
And we hope you enjoy the rest of your
day, thank you very much for joining us.